former San Antonio mayor Julian Castro
emerged onto the national political
stage when he delivered the keynote
speech over here at the 2012 Democratic
convention he went on to serve as US
Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development under President Obama Castro
who was considered a rising star in the
Democratic Party shares his life story
in a new memoir it's called an unlikely
journey waking up from my American dream
his book comes out amid speculation that
he will in fact run for president in
2020 who Leon Castro joins us at the
table hello rising star it's good to be
with you Julian Castro it says there's
speculation because of your words you
did an interview with Rolling Stone and
you said I'll make a final decision
after November but I'm inclined to do it
so what is it going to take for you to
make the decision that you're going to
run well you know between now and
November 6 what I'm doing is helping
candidates that are in the 2018 ballot
but as I do that I'm also getting a
chance to travel around the country and
get a sense of what people are thinking
yeah I've heard very clearly that
there's a lot of dissatisfaction both
with this Congress and also with the
president I believe that people are
looking for a new generation of
leadership they're looking for new faces
and so I'm gonna continue to help folks
that are running before November 6
testing the waters for yourself though
well getting a sense of where people are
at sure
yeah I've been straightforward with
folks if people often play coy about
whether they're thinking about it or not
I said yeah I'm seriously thinking about
it and I'm likely to do it but between
now and November 6 I'm gonna focus on
the people that are on the ballot what
does new generation of leadership really
mean when it's at home though that's a
buzzword we hear a lot what does that
actually mean I think folks that are new
to Washington that bring a perspective
from the outside new faces you know you
always need a good mix in leadership you
need folks with many years of experience
to provide guidance but also folks that
are newer to it and the thing is whether
it's Andrew Gilliam or Stacey Abrams or
in my home state of Texas Bethel Rourke
we have these tremendous new faces in
2018 in the Democratic Party that are
offering strong leadership
that seems to be an implicit criticism
of Joe Biden who may run Mike Bloomberg
who may run the leader of the House of
Representatives Nancy Pelosi who may
become the speaker is that a criticism
of that older generation I think
everybody has their strengths and part
of the 20/20 process is going to be
you're probably going to have you know
15 to 20 people running at the beginning
right I view that as cathartic after
what the Democratic Party went through
in 2016
getting all those folks up there a lot
of talented people some some who have
many years of experience others that are
relatively new and when we get through
that and you get through more debates
and people feel like they've heard their
say from different parts of the
political spectrum yeah I think that
we're gonna be in a stronger position to
defeat Donald Trump in 2020 because of
that you mentioned better or roark
you're sitting among two Texans here nor
myself and and we watched I watched the
debate last night but our work opened it
up speaking Spanish but there is real
concern among Democrats that you're not
going to see a big Latin Latino turnout
in 2018 are you concerned about that oh
you know of course I'm concerned about
it because the numbers have shown
whether it's in midterm elections or
presidential elections that the rate of
Latino voting is not what it should be
and I think what it's going to take to
change that is that it can't be done you
know the six months before an election
or by any one or two candidate it's
going to take folks investing in a
massive and sustained effort to get
Latinos registered and then to turn out
to vote and until that happens I don't
think that the numbers are going to move
that much you write in your book you
talk about your mother having that
passion and being very politically
active it's you kind of what do you need
to do personally and Democrats need to
do to spark that enthusiasm among voters
the mace of this one out well I think
that that Bethel and O'Rourke and Stacey
Abrams and Andrew Gilliam are good
examples of folks that are speaking
directly to the things people care about
you know getting health insurance making
sure that your child can get a good
education talking about improving
neighborhoods and investing in
infrastructure you need to speak to
people where they are
and I think what often gets lost this is
that in the back-and-forth and in DC if
people just throw up their hands and
I've never had so many people tell me
that they stop watching cable news
because they just don't want to hear it
anymore exactly but what about the tone
of the race you know Michelle Obama said
a very classy tone when they go low we
go high
we have prominent Democrats like Eric
Holder who may also be running who says
when they go low we kick them how do you
you have the president of united states
calling a woman horse face where do you
stand on the tone of the title that that
is being said today in this country I
think that we need to call Donald Trump
out and and other folks out who are
uncivil does Eric Holder at the point
you know I'll let the Attorney General
Holder kind of explain what he means but
I would just say you need to be able to
stand up to folks and call them out but
at the same time history teaches us that
especially for Democrats that the ones
who who are ultimately victorious and
who will make change are people that had
a hopeful optimistic vision for the
future that was Barack Obama that was
John Kennedy and at the time that was
Bill Clinton and Jimmy Carter and and so
of course things do change in our
society and in many ways with the media
environment we have it's different but I
don't think that's changed all right
well mr. mayor full disclosure same age
we were in rival high schools Antonio go
MacArthur Brahmas yeah you look a lot
younger than I do
thank you friend an unlikely journey is
on sale now